my next guest is now vowing to fix the
broken system at least in new york and
by the way as deep blue as new york is
remember what happened with glenn
younkin in the commonwealth of virginia
remember how close that gubernatorial
race was in new jersey and nobody was
paying attention to it had we probably
uh murphy would have been thrown out so
yeah this this is a real race in new
york it looks like gubernatorial
candidate congressman lee zeldin
first uh i got to give you a lot of
credit you very quickly went right for
the wrist as a martial artist i respect
your quick response on it i wish you
would wish you would have used the left
hand but the fact that you acted that
quickly prevented him from sticking that
knife
you could he could have hit your carotid
he could have hit your heart
we may not be having this discussion
today you did a great job i congratulate
you
well thank you sean and i also give a
lot of credit to the seven eight nine
ten other people who instantly within a
few moments came to the stage and
tackled this attacker law enforcement
was there just a couple minutes later
and they arrested the guy a lot went
right in the response when i saw him
lunge at me with that weapon in his hand
he was going towards my neck area i just
instinctively went right up to grab that
wrist and i just needed to hold it for a
few moments until that group came in
well i got to tell you something and
we're looking at it from different
angles as you speak here
this was an assassination attempt last
night you predicted he would be let out
on
let out with no bell and sure enough
a guy who's trying to assassinate a
sitting congressman a gubernatorial
candidate is let out on his own
recognizance let out
no bail whatsoever
now this is insanity why so he can try
again
you have a person who is saying you're
done he repeated that he's lunging at me
with this weapon with the two daggers
coming out of it similar to brass
knuckles
he is charged with a a violent felony
and he is instantly released back on the
street because of new york's cashless
bail laws i i saw it coming i wish it
wasn't this way and we keep hearing too
many of these stories as you were just
pointing out some of the decisions with
alvin bragg in the jose alba case there
was another story that came out a couple
weeks ago where two mexican cartel drug
smugglers got caught with 1.2 million
dollars worth of crystal meth and then
they were instantly released back out on
the streets now there's an argument for
a cashless bail the advocates say that
you shouldn't be stuck behind bars on a
low level offense you're not a danger
you're not a flight risk you have a
clean record you shouldn't be stuck
because you can't afford any amount of
bail you have no money i get that but i
would say that if you have 1.2 million
dollars of crystal meth and you don't
have any money to pay your bill your
bail that's on you you're a bad
businessman a bad drug dealer and a bad
criminal we're seeing these stories that
in some of these cases like earlier
today i was in syracuse new york there
was a 93 year old connie torrey who was
murdered by somebody released on castle
spell oh there's more than just data
these are stories these are real lives
cashless bell has been a failure and it
needs to be repealed in new york i'd i'd
like you to explain this we know an
email went out by your opponent kathleen
hulkel the governor's campaign
giving out all the information about
every upcoming campaign event this is
before yesterday
including the dates the times and when
the events are scheduled to begin
now in light of what's been happening
with supreme court justices in light of
the environment that we have in the
country
you would think that maybe she would
have learned something from yesterday my
understanding is
is that she sent more people to follow
you again today
after the assassination attempt on your
life last night
well as i was going through today's
schedule with obviously ramped up
security which will be ramped up for the
remainder of the campaign i was
traveling from onondaga county that's
the county where syracuse is located up
to watertown that's where fort drum is
in jefferson county in the north country
and as we're driving up
this box truck with my face my name on
it criticizing me is following us up to
the next rally so we have rallies
tomorrow all day we have rallies on
sunday all day i would suggest if i was
kathy hokel in her campaign that i would
have this box truck sitting on some
driveway if it was ever going to pop out
it's pretty bad taste and bad judgment
to have it right back on the road
following us around the next day by the
way it's worse than bad judgment it's
dangerous she should look at what
happened last night look at what her
campaign did as that we've been doxing
supreme court justices and their
children where they go to school and the
churches that they attend and the times
they attend church
her giving out the location where you
are every second of every minute of
every day in light of last night was a
bad idea and then she follows you again
today she she's sending more people out
uh did she not see what happened last
night is there is there any has she
as does she ever take a look at what's
happening with these no bail laws does
she not understand the danger of
releasing violent criminals the guy that
attacked you last night could have
killed you if you look at the video
closely and again i look at your hand he
was going right up here for your neck
and i gotta give you credit because with
a lot of strength you grabbed his wrist
and you put him down long enough to get
the assistance that came in behind you
but that could have ended very badly
last night
she has been asked about the need to
overhaul castle's bail her answer was
when the media was asking that she needs
more data
now we know that there's data i would
encourage her just to count up the press
clippings of the amount of cashless bell
stories and that number can be the data
meanwhile just a couple weeks ago after
the supreme court issued the correct
decision to overturn new york's
concealed carry law a week later she
passes all sorts of new laws that are
trampling all over first amendment
rights to trample all over second
amendment rights even more
unconstitutional than what the supreme
court had just ruled upon the the media
asked her well do you have any data to
back up going after these concealed
carry permit holders that they're the
ones causing the problem and she says
she doesn't need data because she's the
governor when she was asked about alvin
bragg
she says cut him some slack he's doing
his job uh he just got there i i say
that on january 1st my first day as
governor it is not just a constitutional
authority it is my constitutional duty
to remove alvin bragg as my first act as
governor and when she was asked just a
little while ago a few days ago about
the jose alba case and alvin bragg she
says that she's not going to get
involved in it at all it's not her
business and i would argue that if there
was one of 19 million new yorkers who
would have a duty or responsibility to
speak up when you have a d.a doing the
wrong thing it is the governor by the
constitution we do not have recall in
this state so it's a whole lot of bad
judgment collectively and she really
needs to go this isn't rock bottom but
we're on her way to rock bottom she has
to go
you know i've had the honor of meeting
your family your kids your wife you have
a lovely family uh thank god you're okay
uh ooze great job you did an amazing job
uh stopping this guy uh
really you could have you could have
been killed last night
uh congressman we're glad you're okay we
wish you well in this campaign this is a
winnable race i hope everybody in new
york is paying attention
uh because you can send a loud message
that would reverberate around the
country we're glad you're safe thanks
for being with us hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else